si algo marcó el reinado de la reina do
el croma marca británica fue el sentido
del deber como chispa que se encendió
incluso cuando amperio británico comenzó
a desmoronarse tras la segunda guerra
mundial
declaró ante todos ustedes que toda mi
vida sea larga o corta estará dedicada a
su servicio y al servicio de nuestra
gran familia imperial a la que todos
pertenecemos
el momento llegó en 1947 era el año de
la independencia de india y reino unido-
estaba económicamente destrozado tras el
conflicto mundial y demasiado pronto una
joven isabel tendría que gobernar más
rápido de lo que nadie podría imaginar
su padre el rey jorge sexto había muerto
prematuramente a los 57 años tras sólo
15 años en el trono dejando navegar a la
nueva reina por un duro camino mucho
antes de lo esperado vería como el
número de personas bajo el término
británico caía en picada de 700 millones
hacia los 5 millones en la siguiente
década y media a medida que las colonias
y los dominios que antes formaban parte
del imperio buscaban la
autodeterminación esperando tras
bastidores la commonwealth una
agrupación que antes estaba unida por la
corona pasaría a estarlo por una
historia unos valores y una democracia
comunes y la reina isabel seguiría
siendo su jefa simbólica desde allí
forjaría su identidad real
en ningún otro lugar la democracia
parlamentaria ha demostrado más
eficazmente su solidez y adaptabilidad a
los tiempos cambiantes
no todo fue camino de rosas los cambios
sociales y políticos del siglo 20 se
acumulaban y hacía tiempo que estaba
claro que la commonwealth no iba a
sustituir al imperio británico
los mercados libres y el comercio global
superaban el comercio entre sus miembros
que no tenían ninguna obligación entre
sí salvo el respeto a la reina isabel
que se ha dedicado a la organización
la política sin embargo desempeñaría un
papel clave ya que las naciones se
marchaban y se reincorporaban y los
gobiernos entraban y salían de escena
como el régimen del apartheid en
sudáfrica toda la comunidad salvo el
reino unido al menos al principio impuso
sanciones contra este en la década de
1980 con el paso de los años la enorme
experiencia acumulada por la reina en la
escena internacional lo hizo más que
mejorar su posición
en el mundo de mañana debemos trabajar
todos juntos con más ahínco que nunca si
queremos ser realmente naciones unidas
aunque las relaciones siguieron siendo
cordiales mientras ella continúa al
frente de la commonwealth algunos
estados miembros deseaban alejarse más
de la sombra del imperio barbados ha
sido el último en optar por romper los
lazos con la monarquía en 2021 y en
otros lugares se pide periódicamente que
las naciones se conviertan en repúblicas
sin embargo las 54 naciones de la
commonwealth tienen que tomar decisiones
como se las arreglará la asociación sin
la extraordinaria relación con la mujer
que ayudó a crearla y qué dirección
tomará sin su figura